المزيد من الجثث طالب والمزيد من الناس
التي تنتظر حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن في اليوم
الحادي عشر على هذا الزلزال المدمر ان
تخرج الجثامين والاشخاص المفقودين من تحت
الانقاض انا كنت رايت بام عيني في هذا
المكان في هذه الزاويه تحديدا قبل قليل
عدد من الجثث منهم للاطفال ولا تزال هنالك
جثث في المبنى الاخر وهؤلاء طبعا يعني
ساسالهم سريعا ومن بعيد لانهم يتناولون
الطعام
كم لديهم من الاشخاص لا يزال تحت الانقاض
صحتين والف هنا سريعا قديش الكم تحت
الانقاذ قديش ضايل ناس تحت الانقاذ
شخص واحد وانت خمس اشخاص شباب معروف في
هذا المبنى ولا هناك
يعني ست اشخاص لا يزالوا تحت الانقاض ان
شاء الله قريبا يعني الامور تكون على ما
يرام اشكركم جزيلا طالب لا تزال عمليات
البحث عن الجثث والمفقودين تحت الانقاض
مستمره ولكن مثلا في هذا المبنى الذي
شاهدنا اخراج يعني هذا الفريض فريق الذي
يظهر امامك في الشاشه طبعا هم يتناولون
الطعام منذ ساعات ربما لم ياكلوا هؤلاء
سوريين تطوعوا للبحث واخراج الجثامين من
تحت الانقاض ويعملون ليلا نهارا
ولا تتوقف اعمالهم انا ساتحرك ايضا الى
المبنى المجاور لان هنالك من ينتظر ايضا
يعني البحث عن الجثامين والمفقودين تحت
الالقاب كنت قبل قليل سريعا يعني اقصتك
قصه التقيت بشاب سوري اخبرني بانه يعمل في
معبر باب الهواء من الفريق الطبي المسؤول
عن نقل الاطفال من سوريا الى تركيا الذين
يحتاج العلاج وهم نقلوا 15 طفل من سوريا
خلال الفتره الماضيه ولديهم مشاكل صحيه
الى هنا الى مدينه انطاكيا وحينما حدث
الزلزال
تضررت المستشفيات وهم فقدوا حاليا يعني
فقدوا اثر هؤلاء الاطفال وبالتالي اسر
هؤلاء الاطفال في سوريا تتصل بهم تسالهم
ولا اجابه لديهم يعني فتشوا المستشفيات
ولم يجدوا فتشوا المقابر ولم يجدوا ولكن
يعني هم في حيره من امرهم الان كيف
يتصرفوا وبالتالي كانت يعني كان موضوع مهم
للغايه الرجل الذي قابلته كان مهموما جدا
وانا على ايه ايه حال ايضا ساتحدث الى هذا
الشاب وهو سوري من سكان هذه المنطقه وله
اقارب تحت هذا البناء واساله كم تبقى لديه
من اشخاص تحت الركام تحياتي يعطيك الف
عافيه بعرف انك تعبان ومرهق كنت تحدثت
اليك وين وصلوا كم شخص لك لا يزال تحت
الانقاض والله الى الان بقي سته اخرجنا
قرابه التسع اشخاص وبقي سته انا في هذا
المبنى 21 شخص نحن مش ضروري تحكي عربي
فصحى احكي براحتك باريحيه لوين وصلوا قديش
ضايل قدامهم تقريبا والله على ما يظهر حسب
مهمه
البواقر وحسب مهمه الاشخاص الذين يعملون
اذا ينتهي العمل الان في الساعه السادسه
ربما نحتاجه يومين او ثلاثه حتى ينتهي
خلصوا على سته انتم راح تكملوا شغل ولا
راح نحاول اننا نكمل شغل نحاول انه المكان
اذا انفتح مثلا قائد نحاول انه ندخل البيت
نلاحظ انه اذا في احد في الداخل نحاول
سريعا بدي تحكيلي ولكن قبل ان نبدا لازم
ان ناخذ اذن من الجندرمون الموجودين تمام
تمام بدي ببساطه تروي لي قصه الطفل اللي
اخرجتوه كان حي وكان يرد وبعد ذلك توفاه
الله لانه ما استطعت والله اكثر ما قهرنا
هذا الشاب
هذا الشاب من اليوم الاول كان اتحدث معه
بشكل واضح جدا ونخور ويصيح يعني يقول لنا
انه اسمه مقداد كان من اول يوم يتحدث بشكل
نظامي ولكن ما قدرنا ان نقدم له اي شيء
الركام كان واصل للطابق الخامس ربما
الايادي فقط موجوده لا يوجد اي معدات
تجينا نحن نحاول لانه نعمل اي شيء
الله يرحمه تعرفتوا عليه هلا الجثه تخرج
تتعرف اليها وبعدين اخرج نتعرف عليها هنا
وبعض الجثث يتعرف عليها من المكان لان بعض
الجثه ربما اصابتها اذيه كبيره جدا تحللت
ابن خالي خمسه اشخاص لولا ان فتحنا وعرفنا
انه هذا طابق وهذا بيته ما تعرف ميزته
للاسف الشديد طالب
سؤال يعني لكي لا يفوت يعني اول شيء الله
يكون في العون حديث يعني استطراضا لما
تقوله وتسال يعني هذا الشاب هنالك حديث في
الاعلام التركي عن المرحله المقبله ستكون
سريعه جدا يعني جرف كبير وسريع ومتواصل
للابنيه المهدمه لانه في روائح الجثث بدات
تفوح وتسبب امراض للاسف الى اي مدى هذا
الكلام صحيح
انا في الحقيقه اشتم الروائح في يعني في
كل مكان حيث نقف بصراحه يعني سواء في
المبنى هناك او هنا حيث اقف نعم هنالك
روائح والجثث التي تخرج يعني جثث يعني
بدات تتحلل صراحه وبالتالي نعم هنالك
روائح يعني كثيره ومساله الجرف والعمل
السريع لا لا اعلم ما مدى سماح الاسر التي
تنتظر الجثامين ان يسمحوا لي ان يسمحوا
بها لانه انا اعتقد انه هذا سيخلق نوع من
التوتر لانه الناس لا تزال كما قلت لك
لليوم 11 تبيت في الشارع الى جانب
البنايات هؤلاء لم يغادروا مثلا مع ساعات
الليل تعيش يتدفق عليها ويعني يبقوا
حاضرين في المكان خشيه ان تضيع اي جثه
عمار الهندي موفد العربيه من هاتاي شكرا
جزيلا لك عمار على كل هذه المتابعه